ah
[Música]
buenas noches a todos
estamos en tiempos en que las redes
sociales y las plataformas nos piden que
digamos algo sobre nosotros o lo que se
llama la bio de biografía
y yo encontré una manera de definir qué
es lo que hago y lo que hago de hecho
son muchas cosas al igual que cualquiera
de ustedes entonces encontré el término
perfecto para describir lo que hago yo
soy un obrero del entretenimiento 6 y
ustedes dirán como algo tan tan noble
como el ser obrero relacionado de la
construcción se puede asociar algo tan
trivial o sin importancia como el
entretenimiento permítanme entonces
contarles qué es el entretenimiento el
entretenimiento si nos remitimos a la
etimología de la palabra viene del
francés antes de venir
aunque tenía
mantener unido
otra definición de entretenimiento
apunta a que entretenimiento es
cualquier cosa que logre captar y
mantener nuestra atención
en este momento
yo tengo de ustedes
seguramente vuestro capital más valioso
en este momento tengo su tiempo tengo su
energía tengo su atención
es muy difícil querer renunciar a algo
tan importante porque con esos tres
elementos podemos sumarle la variable
amor bueno si tengo su amor también es
bienvenido me encanta esa idea
ese es el motor de todo lo que hacemos
tiempo energía atención amor todo eso es
entretenimiento
por eso me define a mí mismo como un
obrero de entretenimiento cuando arranca
todo esto
ahí
y cuando empecé a formarme como obrero
del entretenimiento si ese es el pequeño
christian
ocurre que esta anécdota me lleva al
patio de mi escuela
todos tienen presentes los actos
escolares cuando habla la directora de
ese acto escolar de patio donde nunca
faltan los acoples de micrófono lo tiene
clarísimo el que arranca diciendo padres
madres miembro de comisión momento
perfecto
arranca hablar la directora
lo que está diciendo no prende entre el
público infantil entonces qué hacemos
los niños del patio que hacemos le
tiramos un papelito al otro sacamos la
pis lo ponemos la trenza recién armada
de la compañera de adelante
porque porque nosotros de alguna manera
estamos deseando poner nuestra atención
nuestro tiempo de nuestra energía pero
lo único que estamos recibiendo son
palabras y nosotros queremos ser
entretenidos no sólo ser receptores de
palabras y está bien porque nuestro
tiempo nuestra energía nuestra atención
vale mucho por eso también tenemos baja
tolerancia al aburrimiento tal es así
que como no somos seres unidimensionales
queremos estar multi entretenidos por
eso seguramente mientras yo estoy
hablando alguno todavía está con el
celular diciendo acá con arroba
christian font en text y está bien si
están difundiendo el evento está bien
pero eso desde siempre necesitamos estar
multi entretenidos por eso nos llevamos
el celular para ir a
vuelvo vuelvo al entretenimiento el
mundo del espectáculo
nos ha hecho creer que quienes
entretienen son elegidos actores
actrices bailarines músicos artistas
también nos ha hecho creer que el
entretenimiento tiene que ser solamente
divertido ameno yo puedo mirar un cuadro
estar muy entretenido y no
necesariamente tener que reírme o
divertirme porque todo lo que logré
capturar nuestra atención reitero es el
entretenimiento nos podemos entretener
con lo que a cada uno de nosotros se nos
ocurra buscamos la manera de zafar del
aburrimiento a veces mal saben por qué
porque caramba es necesario aburrirse es
muy importante ahora me cuesta a veces
hacérselo entender a mis hijos que el
aburrimiento es posiblemente el mayor
motor de creatividad y entretenimiento
que tenemos
el año pasado ya parece cosa de hace
cinco o seis años pero el año pasado
logramos demostrar que combatimos el
aburrimiento con la primera cosa que nos
quieran imponer
tecnología de punta
y vos lo miraba y lo miraba y te
preguntaban y qué es eso que hace
cómo se llamaba buena pregunta que
formulan por ahí es el único juguete con
nombre de agente secreto de película
inglesa fidget spinner
el espinar
acá lo hicimos funcionar a base de
uruguay uruguay no lo compramos todo
cuando salía 400 pesos y a los 3 meses
lo regalaron con un kilo de limones pero
ya lo habíamos comprado
y lo mirábamos girar y lo mirábamos
girar porque porque estábamos
combatiendo el aburrimiento pero lo
mejor porque este triangulito con un
rulemán no divertida no se entretenía y
eso para nosotros es importante ahora
bien uno se puede entretener con las
cosas más simples las cosas más
sencillas nos pueden generar
entretenimiento yo por ejemplo puedo
pasar horas mirando una fuente
capas que alguna ustedes les pasa yo
puedo pasarme muchos ratos mirando la
fuente como esta
yo sé que es un chiste tonto pero tienen
que entender que entretener tiene sus
riesgos por suerte se rieron
ahora bien ahora bien
vuelvo a la pregunta todos podemos
entretener la respuesta es claramente si
todos y cada uno de ustedes portan una
carga de datos y de información que
ustedes tienen y yo no y en la cual a mí
me gustaría acceder
yo no conozco a la inmensa mayoría de
ustedes pero estoy seguro que tendríamos
no menos de 20 cosas en común sobre las
cuales nos gustaría hablar con mucho
entusiasmo
ahora bien necesitamos estar dispuestos
a extraer esos datos a decodificar la
información que tiene el resto para
entretener hay un elemento indispensable
quieren saber cuáles quieren saber qué
es lo que precisan todos ustedes para
entretener quieren saber cuáles se lo
quieren saber estarán todos atentos lo
voy a decir lo voy a decir lo digo lo
que necesitan para entretener el único
elemento indispensable es
al otro
festejos
[Aplausos]
hoy por hoy salir del conformismo
escapar del conformismo es escuchar al
otro leer al otro intentar entender al
otro no adaptar al otro a nuestra
realidad y a nuestra conveniencia
meternos por un momento en la realidad
del otro eso es lo más difícil
hoy por hoy twitter que es una red
social en la que por ejemplo yo
incursionó seguramente muchos de ustedes
también y nos creemos que a veces en
twitter estamos formando opinión y
generando agendas
estáis mintiendo a que el primer eslogan
el primer eslogan de twitter era join
the conversation un ansia la
conversación y por el twitter es algo
así como what's my monólogo miren mi
monólogo miren y aplaudan lo denle me
gusta pero eso no es tratar de entender
al otro ni leer al otro paréntesis
y aquí tenemos al otro porque esto es de
ida y vuelta
el monólogo el monólogo es una de las
formas que adquieren para comunicarse
los gurús
y tenemos uno que se parece bastante a
mí en la murga en los diablos verdes en
el año 2013
los gurús
o gurús es no sé cuál es el plural de
guru
gurisas si es mujer
logros hoy por hoy más que estar
vinculados a la noción primera del
hinduismo de guía espiritual están
vinculados a una cuestión más occidental
y moderna de cosas más bien frívolas es
decir hay gurús de la robótica gurú de
la moda gurú deportivo de gurús de lo
que sea no pero acá en uruguay el gurú
no funciona es como nuestra nuestra
tabla de salvación en este gran templo
2.0 acan no te crece en uruguay no te
cree seguro nada no fue un canguro
porque acá meten de que va a ser guru
este si no terminó los estudios entender
como si hubiera alguna relación entre
vida académica y vida espiritual no pero
aquí que va a ser gurú estés y escúchame
que arranque para las 8 horas gurú de
que ojo que el gurú seguro las 24 horas
pero acá en uruguay no compramos esa y
porque nuestra tabla de salvación porque
el gurú de alguna manera predice algo
hacia el universo pero siempre deja
fuera a alguien a quién
al otro
en la feria de fráncfort de 2008
feria del libro de frankfurt de 2008 los
gurús del mundo editorial dijeron para
2018 no va a haber más libros el libro
el libro físico el libro de tapa y
páginas s
2018 no armas libro me imagino que todos
tiraron sus bibliotecas nadie más tiene
libros en su casa qué pasa
se olvidaron del otro s
que no te compra que él es lo más grande
que hay que ahora hay que leer todo en
tablet y sigue acumulando libros porque
vos en definitiva guru lo dejaste afuera
al otro
porque es importante escuchar al otro
porque cada vez tenemos menos ganas de
saber qué es lo que tiene para decir
esta foto
es casi casi igual a la situación que
les voy a describir esta porque la saqué
de un banco de imágenes por eso le dio
feriado de viernes santo estoy en la
radio en la radio disponemos de toda la
tecnología que precisamos y tenemos
cuenta en todas las redes sociales con
nuestro equipo tenemos incluso una
columna de divulgación de cosas
tecnológicas y en fin nos sentimos
orgullosos de hasta tenemos sms para
aquellos nostálgicos
entonces se me da por preguntarle a la
gente cuéntennos mandando una foto al
número de whatsapp de la radio
cuéntennos cómo nos están escuchando yo
me imaginaba por ejemplo una taza de
café una foto en el alto de un semáforo
una captura de pantalla de la aplicación
tunein donde nos estaban sintonizando a
través de precisamente una aplicación y
lo primero que llegó fue esto solo que
en vez de estar apoyado en ese lindo
deck de madera la radio portátil estaba
colgada de un peral
y abajo un escueto mensaje que decía acá
haciendo las tareas del campo y eso me
recordó al otro yo no le estaba hablando
al otro yo no le estaba de alguna manera
considerando yo ya había formateado a mi
oyente ideal
mandando más capturas de pantallas de
aplicación tazas de café cervezas
artesanales y cosas mucho más cool pero
no por suerte el otro me vino a recordar
que estaba ahí con su radio a pilas
colgada de un peral participando
colectivamente de la audiencia de un
programa radial
el gran desafío hoy por hoy que tenemos
todos todos
es no anular al otro aún cuando se
encuentre en la vereda opuesta de
nuestro pensamiento porque tenemos un
montón de herramientas hoy te dejo de
seguir
de bloqueo
me voy del grupo
lalalala no te escucho
es un berrinche virtual
dejamos de lado el otro es como si
estuviéramos barriendo abajo de la
alfombra
barremos si trabajo en la alfombra sigue
estando en lo que no queremos ver
el otro va a recibir en algún momento va
a hacernos saber que no es que a
nosotros no nos interesa lo que tenga
para decir que a nosotros no nos
interesa
de qué manera nos puede entretener el
otro porque porque lo estamos anulando
y el otro en algún momento va a volver
por sus fueros va a volver en una forma
seguramente mucho menos amable va por
ejemplo a expresarse en las urnas
de repente frente a un montón de
plataformas y consignas no muy alineadas
con la democracia y te va a hacer saber
qué bueno lo escuchaste entonces te va a
hacer saber que el otro sigue estando
por eso para que la construcción
colectiva se siga dando a todos los
niveles y para entender mejor el mundo
en que vivimos aunque no nos guste el
otro está ahí y nos puede entretener y
podemos entretenerlos y podemos por un
momento generar esa empatía y no anular
al otro no enseguida llenar nuestra
cuenta nuestro muro de facebook nuestra
timeline de twitter de gente cuentas que
solamente responden a nuestra idea a
nuestra forma de ver el mundo a nuestros
iguales a los que se entretienen igual
que nosotros
si algo tenemos hoy por hoy como tarea
todos para salir del conformismo que es
que nos aplauda en el monólogo es
escuchar y tratar de entender al otro
para
para cerrar esta esta hermosa charla en
este hermoso lugar en esta noche
increíble quiero compartir con ustedes
tres minutos de una obra
cuasi renacentista
capaz que hay algún otro u otra que
conoce lo que estamos por ver no está en
netflix no está en las plataformas ni va
a ser lo más difundido de la
cinematografía universal pero créanme
que esto es una obra maestra es la
película del año 1924 sherlock junior
escrita dirigida y actuada por un señor
llamado buster keaton
en ser los juniors buster keaton es un
proyeccionista
a ver si tenemos suerte de que arranque
ayer
buster keaton es un proyeccionista que
sale del conformismo de su tarea como
proyeccionista porque se duerme porque
ve la misma película una y otra vez
entonces qué es lo que hace entre la
pantalla y se enoja con el protagonista
pero por supuesto protagonista está
dentro de la pantalla tiene todas las de
ganar y ahí tiene chicos que lleva algo
me pasó
el sueño que puede ingresar a otro mundo
pero tiene sus riesgos ahora no se va a
conformar con ser sólo el proyeccionista
mira que le dice la gente medio también
quiero participar ingresa la película
logra ingresar a la película
quiere hablar con el otro porque él
mismo también es el otro
y a veces ingresar a otro mundo también
tiene sus riesgos como pueden ver a
continuación
[Música]
ah
y tanto
d
a mí
[Música]
en él
buster keaton un obrero del
entretenimiento
regalen se regalen se el placer de
entretener regalen se el placer de ser
entretenidos por el otro por la otra
porque ustedes quieran buenas noches
muchas gracias